This isn't computer animation
or a trick of the light.
A wood-carved city
actually just popped out
of that chunk of a tree,
and it can pop right back in!
So what's going on?
Artist Uli Kirchler works
with a totally unexpected
form of art that requires
a tough-to-navigate canvas.
He uses burls, these bulbous
and kind of gross growths
found on the side of trees.
Look inside them and you'll
see amazing swirling patterns.
But when Uli looks inside,
he sees an opportunity
to create a pop-up city
that could take him hours
to meticulously carve
but that he can play with for a lifetime.
Uli's pieces appear right before your eyes
but also disappear in an instant.
That's because the carvings
work like an extendable telescope.
So, how exactly does he carve
such intricate castles into a tree trunk?
And how exactly do they work?
He chooses to use burls
because each of them have a
natural edge that's unique,
making each piece he makes one of a kind.
Uli carves into those natural edges
using different types of saws.
He does most of his
cutting with a scroll saw.
The trick to getting his pieces just right
is to cut into the wood at a slight angle.
This way, the pieces
are able to move around
without flying right out.
This also means each level of the castle
will fit inside the one underneath it,
creating a telescopic effect.
The castles will be able to expand out
and collapse back into each other.
Uli Kirchler: I have to be very careful,
especially if it's a bigger piece.
And, often, I stand at my scroll saw,
I feel my heart pounding,
knowing I cannot mess up;
otherwise, I'm risking to lose the piece.
Narrator: He maps out where he'll place
all the hidden doors and windows
before he starts cutting.
Then, he takes each individual
level of the castle out
and drills holes where
all the details will go.
This way, he can place them
directly under the scroll saw
in order to make perfect cuts.
Uli: Since I'm a designer as well,
there has to be a certain distance
between the different sections.
So, I intuitively have
to guess that angle.
Narrator: The hardest part
of Uli's process, though?
Getting the angles just right.
Because the density of the
raw wood he uses differs,
he has to approach each piece differently.
Getting those angles right every time
has taken him years of practice.
Uli: Two decades and more of scroll-sawing
allowed me to refine a
technique and push it further.
It totally changed my life.
Narrator: After everything is cut,
he adds the final finishing
touches and sands the piece.
Then, it's completed with finishing oil.
For the past couple of years,
Uli has been selling his castles
at the Portland Saturday
Market every weekend.
His favorite part?
Watching people react to his work.
(snaps)
(laughing)
Shopper: Whoa!
That is cool!
Shopper: OK, can you
do that one more time?
(laughing)